[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so we do have primary
elections today a three of the four
scheduled primaries are happening today
despite what is going on with
coronavirus Arizona Florida Illinois and
Ohio were scheduled to vote now Ohio
Governor Mike DeWine who's a Republican
announced polls are closed the Ohio
primary is postponed and tentatively for
June although who on earth knows at this
point what our world will look like in
three months it's hard to imagine what
it'll even look like in ten days if the
current infection numbers continue this
is do or die for Bernie I mean if Joe
Biden picks up more than an additional
hundred delegate lead on Bernie tonight
you know Bernie has a hypothetical path
right now although it's unlikely it's
already a longshot if Bernie Falls
another hundred delegates behind tonight
it's it's essentially done so we'll look
at national polling will look at
delegate counts will look at state polls
and figure out sort of what to expect
tonight in terms of the delegate count
going in it's a hundred and fifty one
delegate lead for Joseph R Biden Jr 894
to 743 we believed that tonight we were
going to have a total of five hundred
seventy seven delegates available that's
Arizona Florida Illinois and Ohio
Florida of course the big prize with 219
delegates Ohio postponing their primary
so the hundred and thirty six delegates
out of Ohio will be saved for another
day so to speak now in terms of the
polling as you know nationally Bernie
Sanders has hit a ceiling of about 36%
and nationally Joe Biden is leading
last dozen or so poles most recently by
as much as 29 Bernie did manage to get
38% in one in the latest economist
YouGov poll but the numbers looking very
very solid for the former vice president
looking state-by-state at polling in the
states that were scheduled to vote today
in Arizona Joe Biden averaging plus 18
in Florida Joe Biden averaging plus 39
Illinois has Biden at plus 29 and a half
and Ohio which again has postponed their
primaries as of now until sometime in
June who knows a Biden was up 22 and a
half I'm not even going to do delegate
estimates for what it will look like at
the end of the night I mean I think we
all know that with these margins if the
margins hold it's a very bad night for
Bernie Sanders and a huge debate over
whether anybody should be voting at all
because of what you know we have on the
one hand and we'll get to it Donald from
yesterday saying officially for the
country you shouldn't have more than ten
people together you kids shouldn't be at
schools restaurants and bars should
close and we may have to continue some
version of this up until July or August
and then meanwhile Florida Illinois and
Arizona have huge crowds of people
presumably assuming people are showing
up to vote and we will we will find out
in just a few hours congregating and
doing all of the things Donald Trump
says they are not supposed to do there
was the idea that maybe the debate
between Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden on
Sunday night would change the numbers it
didn't we got we now have post debate
polls and the numbers are essentially
unchanged it was scheduled to be a
debate with an audience in Arizona
because of the virus the change was made
to do it in a studio with just the
candidates and three moderators with CNN
in Washington DC and again the you know
I think that there were a lot of people
emailing me expecting Biden to implode
unable to speak because of his supposed
dementia which has been a story being
pushed not only by people on the right
but also some people on the line
yeah and the problem is the expectation
was that Biden would so miserably
implode Biden just had to be coherent
for the debate and he was unlikely to
really be damaged and that's what
happened you know there there were some
disagreements disagreements about how to
deal with the virus there I think
Bernie's strongest moment during the
two-person debate on Sunday night was
when they started talking about Social
Security but again it didn't seem like
it was going to make a difference I
tweeted that I didn't think it was going
to make a difference we now have debate
but post debate polling and it has not
made a difference so far so we are going
to know very soon
what at least in Arizona Illinois and
Florida Democratic voters who choose to
go have decided the other idea that's
been floated has been because old folks
are more at risk if they get the virus
old folks may disproportionately stay
home which will hurt Biden and help
Bernie that was floated last week as
well now of course in a week a lot has
changed when it comes to the virus and
to people being told to stay home we'll
know within hours at this point I don't
know that it makes much sense to
speculate beyond these ideas we will
have a results live stream starting
tonight at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time on
Twitch YouTube and Facebook live I hope
you'll join me we will take in the
results together in what are very very
strange times at this point quite
frankly I for me its but every morning I
wake up sometimes a few minutes before
my alarm sometimes with my alarm and
there's I I would call it a five-second
period it's probably more a fraction of
a second where I forget what's going on
with current coronavirus it feels normal
for just like a fraction of a second and
then I remember that that's not the case
and we've shifted around our entire
production to adjust to trying to stay
away from people and crowds I am you
know mostly just home this could go on
for months we don't know but there is
that split second in the morning where
it just feels normal
I'm wondering if other people are
experiencing that these are I think we
will all
remember living through this those that
do and of course tragically not
everybody will those that live through
this will certainly remember this for
the rest of our lives
yesterday the Dow Jones Industrial
Average had once again a disastrous
disastrous day falling twelve point nine
three percent in a single trading day
that is just under 3,000 points in one
day if we look at the worst declines in
history by points yesterday was the
worst day ever now I know I said this
two weeks ago and I said it twice last
week it keeps happening and in fact if
you look at this biggest single-day
point declines in history nine of the
largest fifteen point declines in
history have come in the last few weeks
now if we look at declines by percentage
which may be more valuable in some sense
yesterday was the second worst stock
market declined by percentage ever at
twelve point 93 percent the only time
that the stock market had a worse day
than yesterday on a percentage basis was
the day known as Black Monday October 19
1987 a historically bad day that's the
only day that was the worst day than
yesterday by percentage and otherwise
you're looking at worse than the 1920s
Great Depression numbers okay not the
2008 Great Recession yesterday stocks
were down more by percentage than during
any day of the Great Depression of the
1920s think about that and this has now
wiped out all of the gains of the Trump
stock market of the last 38 months when
Donald Trump took office the Dow was
just a few points under 20100 that's
where we ended yesterday 20,000 188
we're back to where we were all of the
gains of the Trump administration are
gone and unfortunately this level of
erratic stock market performance and the
declines are likely not over we could
have a long way
entire industries are unfortunately
going to be decimated so the question is
what can we do the Fed printing money is
having minimal impact the usual suspects
are going to get bailed out the airlines
the cruise ship companies and many more
but what about individuals what about
small businesses there's going to be
some capital injections money made
available through small business
association loans there will be some
other stimulus but there will be
businesses destroyed by this I don't
know how the countless restaurants that
are currently relegated to takeout and
delivery only survive this their
landlords are going to want rent unless
rent is suspended or forgiven or made up
by the government many restaurant owners
are gonna say I just have to walk away I
have to walk away from the restaurant
even with rent support given by state or
federal government states or state or
federal governments many restaurants are
not going to survive because they're
just not going to make enough money and
of money so right away we probably need
a combination of some kind of universal
basic income for people making under X
amount or businesses whose gross
revenues are under Y amount I don't know
what those numbers are but we probably
need something like that Mitt Romney has
suggested a thousand a month ROH Khanna
has a proposal that's a six thousand
dollar one-time payment for people
making under 65 K we need something like
that number two we are going to need the
government to step in and say we will
make or guarantee mortgage payments rent
payments I mean I'm thinking out loud
here all non-essential travel is going
to have to be stopped what counts as
essential travel I don't know but you've
got to define it somehow people need to
stop moving around red states are filled
with people just partying at beaches in
close proximity these are idiots these
are bad people some of them may be
Donald Trump yesterday finally saying
this is not under control will make a
difference and it's tragic in many ways
this is why it's crucial that we grin
and bear it
now we stay home we try to turn the
corner on new infections but it is not
looking good the latest numbers as of an
hour ago were a hundred and eighty eight
thousand official cases worldwide I mean
the number is probably millions
worldwide at this point there are s two
it's that Ohio has a hundred thousand
actual infections their estimates that
the country the US has 500,000 or
750,000 in we just don't know
we know the death toll currently has
passed seventy five hundred and we must
get it under control
the economy will suffer for a while it's
this is going to be ugly but if we don't
work together it's only going to be
worse let me know what you're doing what
are you able to do on Twitter I'm on
Twitter at V Pakman follow me let me
know what you've got going on the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are Gary pickle and was set Brodie
Gary and was set thank you so much I
appreciate your support and I really
appreciate the support of everybody
who's been grabbing memberships as we
have completely sort of realigned and
and reprogrammed how we are doing the
show to in light of the virus I also
want to say thanks to Scott Dowson Scott
is today's sustaining member of the day
Scotsmen been a member for five years
grab a membership it's quick it's easy
it's cheap at join pakman.com you all
know that I don't think Donald Trump is
a good president I don't think he's an
honest person I don't think he's
competent I believe he's way in over his
head he's the worst president I've
personally lived through but I also hope
you know that when Trump or anyone does
the right thing I'm not afraid to say it
and in some small ways Donald Trump did
some good things yesterday while also
doing many many bad things during his
coronavirus press conference and later
on Twitter Trump gave what for him again
for him was his most presidential
statement and briefing on coronavirus
and maybe on anything since the start of
his presidency because Trump came out
and he didn't immediately brag
uncontrollably about how great his
response has been he was initially sober
and quite frankly scared looking and
saying we need to take some serious
precautions and outlining a list of
those behavior changes that need to
happen he actually looked like when I
say scared he looked like he understood
the gravity of the situation and he
admitted coronavirus is not under
control
new guidelines recommended by Trump
yesterday home school all kids don't go
to bars don't go to restaurants no
gatherings of more than 10 people okay
no idea whether state governors will put
those
policies into action but we have to
start getting through to the trumpets
who are acting like nothing is going on
spreading the disease going to beaches
going to concerts and bragging about it
and that's why this matters Trump went
on to say a whole bunch of crazy stuff
and lies and tweets and I'll tell you
about it but even Trump saying this
matters because this is just math okay
his red state followers have not been
taking this seriously and they are
preventing us from limiting transmission
they've been going to beaches and
concerts and parties and spreading the
disease here is Trump obviously lying
about never having previously said the
virus was under control but at least he
is saying no the virus is not under
control and apologies about the the
tinny audio on this clip we are doing a
very good job within the confines of
what we're dealing with we're doing a
very good job there's been a there's
been a tremendous amount of the the way
they're working together they're working
hand-in-hand I think they're doing
really a great job and from that
standpoint that's what I was referring
to yes control for any place in the
world
so still some deception saying I never
said it was under control that's not
true that's a lie he said it was under
control many many times but he's at
least admitting it is not under control
Trump says the new guidelines might be
necessary might be necessary until July
or August that is mind blowing ly
inconceivable to tens of millions of
Americans but here is Trump laying out
what he sees as the worst case scenario
you have any kind of estimate that if
Americans really were to band together
do with the White House and suggesting
how quickly
my favorite question asked it all the
time how many times a day I think I
asked them that question every day and I
speak to dev where I speak to a lot of
them I get the opinion so it seems to me
that if we do a really good job will not
only hold the death down to a level that
is much lower than the other way had we
not done a good job but people are
talking about july/august something like
that so it could be right in that period
of time where it I say wash it washes
through other people don't like that
term but word washes through this the
new normal until item some we'll see
what happens but they think August could
be July to be longer than that but I've
asked that question many many times yet
now where he did go off the rails was
raiding his response to the virus as a
10 out of 10 and on a scale of one to
ten how would you rate your response to
this crisis I'd read it a tenth I think
we've done a great job yeah that that's
crazy and the so that's the the regular
old Trump we know coming out he also
kept repeating who could have imagined
this a month ago nobody imagined this
could happen a month ago
that's not presidential and that's not
honest we've been covering it for months
and we weren't even particularly early
to the game we've all been warning for
months that this is exactly the
situation that could develop and it has
and then also later in the day Donald
Trump losing all presidential political
capital that he gained with the
statement by tweeting about the
so-called Chinese virus saying the
United States will be powerfully
supporting those industries like
Airlines and others that are
particularly affected by the Chinese
virus we will be stronger than ever
before Chinese virus of course
completely xenophobic and discriminatory
and counterproductive in every way
particularly when now China actually is
not the epicenter nor the place with the
most active cases and they have it under
control completely meaningless statement
and then again this morning Cuomo wants
all states to be treated the same but
all states aren't the same
some are being hit hard by the Chinese
virus some are being hit practically not
at all New York is a very big hot spot
wet West Virginia has thus far zero
cases Andrew keep politics out of it of
course it is very political to rebrand
it the Chinese virus this is the same
racist xenophobic blame China blame
Chinese people stuff and Trump clearly
not able to remain a normal person or
remotely presidential for more than a
few minutes at the time yesterday
confirm that but I will take the small
win where I can get it Trump saying not
under control don't go to school don't
go to bars don't congregate in groups of
more than ten don't go to restaurants
and it and this could last until July or
August it's something that will
hopefully influence his followers
Massachusetts is basically shut down in
terms of the restaurant industry in
terms of entertainment in terms of all
of that stuff gyms are shut down
individual restaurants at least as far
as we know aren't going to be bailed out
like the airlines and the cruise ship
industry and oil companies or anybody
else and even if this goes on until only
June the recovery time for some
industries is potentially going to be
years long many businesses are not going
to return from this and that's horrible
but we have to do what we have to do and
that's why we're taking it so seriously
here not taking it very seriously as Fox
News yesterday I had video view of
congressman Devin Nunez suggesting that
the corona virus pandemic is a great
time to go to restaurants because they
won't be busy you'll be able to get
right in and get yourself a beautiful
table we now have video of the buffoons
at Fox and Friends which Trump watches
remember saying this is a great time to
fly despite warnings from every public
health organization in the world saying
the opposite
first reminder this was Devon Nunez we
played this clip for you yesterday and
there's a lot of concerns with the
economy here because people are scared
to go out but I will just say one of the
things you can do if you're healthy you
and your family it's a great time to
just go out go to a local restaurant
yeah likely you can get in get in easily
there's
you know let's not hurt the working
people in this country that are relying
on wages and tips to keep their small
business run do that don't run to the I
understand I just don't run to the
grocery store and buy you know four
thousand dollars of food you know go to
your local local park very sympathetic
to what's going on okay so now let's get
to Fox and Friends
here's Ainsley Earhardt on Fox & Friends
it's actually the safest time to fly
everyone I know that's flying right now
terminals are pretty much dead ghost
towns and then the plains remember back
in the day when you had a seat next to
you possibly empty you could stretch out
a little more it's like that on every
flight now what what do you mean when I
used to fly years ago right
my wife was flying yesterday every seat
on the plane was taken really absolutely
and bacon was taken there were people
leaving New York to head down to Florida
what wouldn't you yesterday the mayor
declared a state of emergency here so
there it is great time to fly and notice
Steve Doocy adding idiocy to idiocy
saying we have a state of emergency here
in New York why not go down to Florida
spread germs on the plane and then
spread them in Florida where they didn't
at least as of then have a state of
emergency
untrue at this point what's going on in
Florida people congregating at beaches
people go into concerts people go into
bars restaurants spreading spreading
spreading Florida increasingly a cluster
of coronavirus infection irresponsible
people and remember that Fox News his
own audience skews older is it a good
strategy to suggest your audience behave
in a way that will kill them off and
thus hurt your ratings I mean I this is
obviously it's all immoral and unethical
and wrong what they're doing but even
from a business strategy does this makes
sense make it likely that the people
watching you will be more likely to die
if they follow your recommendations and
I really hope that Donald Trump
yesterday during his press conference
admitting that coronavirus is not under
control that we are possibly in a
recession that people need to stay home
I hope that this is going to make an
impact because too many Republican
governors plus the clowns at Fox News
Plus
rush limbaugh plus the rest of them
they've been almost urging people to
ignore the recommendations from doctors
and public health officials and pandemic
infection outbreak experts those are the
people we should be listening to
not Ainsley Earhardt and Steve douchey
these people are dangerous this is not a
joke this business plan of theirs will
kill their own viewers but this is a
sort of negligence at a mass scale I
don't know how this can be called news
of any kind and of course there is no
distinction on Fox News between news and
opinion and in reality they claim
there's a distinction and you have
people who are not only a particular
risk if they do this and they fly and
they go to the beach and they go to
restaurants and do all this stuff it's
not just that there are people because
of both ignorance in our country Fox
News not distinguishing between news and
opinion and the fact that people can't
tell the difference between news news
and opinion in many cases you have
people who think that that's news they
see they see Ainsley Earhardt saying
it's so convenient to fly right now they
consider that equivalent to a doctor
specializing in infections saying
something different it's equivalent
because of lack of media literacy
because of Fox News deliberately
blurring the difference between their
news and opinion it's kind of all
infected with with opinion anyway as we
know and simply because of the ignorance
that is so widespread in this country
the reporting about coronavirus on fox
news has been and continues to be a
public health hazard and we're going to
have more clips on the shows Instagram
page I encourage you to follow us there
at David Pakman show oh and also I
posted my work from home setup yesterday
to my Instagram David Pakman
follow me check it out let me know what
you're doing
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it's so great to welcome
back to the program today Lee McEntire
who's a research fellow at the Center
for philosophy and history of science at
Boston University also author of the
book post truth which we are linking to
today from the YouTube video for this
interview Lee it's so great to have you
back
great thank you so much for having me
back so a lot of what is in your book
post truth relates so significantly to
what we've seen in media and heard from
the federal government led by Donald
Trump about coronavirus over the last
several months we've seen everything
from denial to disinformation to cloudy
data about what is going on test results
that can't really be relied upon because
we're not really testing so let's sort
of to open the conversation how does
your sort of analysis that you do in the
book apply to what we're living through
right now well unfortunately it applies
directly I wrote the book the book is
published two years ago I had no clue
about coronavirus but at the end of the
book I predicted that we were in for a
hard correction from reality if we
stayed on the route that we were on
Trump has been running this playbook for
a very long time if you look at the
things that he was initially lying about
the size of his inauguration crowd
whether he had whether there were
illegal voters and he'd actually won the
popular vote those are things that are
important but he wasn't held accountable
for them and there you might say that in
a way you know that they weren't
life-and-death matters well we're now to
a life and death matter and I think what
happened is he got away with those kind
of lies what are they up to now 15,000
counted through the Washington Post he
he got so used to it and you know the
little boy who cried wolf
and here we are and we're now getting
that hard check from reality where he's
just learned that he can get away with
lying and distracting and all the other
things but we're now all undergoing the
consequences of that and we're about to
get within the next ten days a very hard
check from reality one of the things
that is sometimes debated now is is it
that facts don't matter or is it that
it's very easy to get whatever facts you
sort of want with the widespread
availability of both you know liars and
government and actual propaganda news
and so on with the coronavirus thing it
doesn't seem that it's that facts don't
matter it's that it's very easy to find
a set of facts or suppose it facts that
say this isn't really serious it's sort
of like the flu keep going to the beach
keep going to concerts all of this sort
of stuff it's it's going to pass it's
all under control so my instinct is it's
not that the facts don't matter is that
there's facts available for whoever
wants to find somebody asserting one
thing or the other thing as is
convenient what's your sense of that no
I I think you're right I mean if facts
didn't matter they wouldn't be trying so
hard to spin the narrative or you know
look for alternative facts in in my book
I define post truth as the political
subordination of reality so it's not
that truth doesn't matter or that when
you say you're in atropos truth era
that's not to say that truth doesn't
matter that nobody cares about truth
anymore it means that we're living in an
era in which truth is endangered and the
thing that's endangering it is that post
truth is really a tactic that's used by
authoritarians and their wannabes to
control the narrative because that you
can control the narrative and the
information flow maybe you can control
the population and so it's a it's a very
dangerous thing that you know we can
read out in many different examples
there there are a number of different
examples we're now living through a
moment what I think that
host truth is particularly visible just
because so many people are paying
attention so many people are threatened
by lies and denial you know all of a
sudden we're all on the same boat and
we're not just it's not just that we're
getting our information from different
sources we're all seeing the same things
happening in our neighborhood what are
some of the strategies you suggest
people adopt to find out the truth and
to cut the risk of maybe signal boosting
disinformation I mean a great example is
every couple of days I read or someone
writes to me hey they're testing
chloroquine as a possible coronavirus
treatment and before I say that to my
audience I want to figure out am I doing
the equivalent of spreading anti-vaxxer
or am i reporting on something that's
really going on what's the right process
that you recommend people go through to
figure out what's what's real it's it's
tough because the minute you report on a
lie you've amplified the lie and
cognitive scientists have shown that
people will remember the lie they won't
remember whether it was true they won't
remember the source so just remember
that they heard it and so the thing
that's very important to do for anybody
in the media is when you're going to
report on false information they say the
false information is a story because a
prominent person said it I recommend
that what people do is follow the advice
of the psychologist George Lakoff who
said that what we need is a truth
sandwich you start off by telling the
truth then you report on the lie as a
lie and then you fact check it you show
why maybe the person was motivated to do
it and what's wrong with it so it's very
important for folks not to as you said
amplify false information because that
just puts it out there and then it it
goes and goes where are some of the
centers of of propagating so-called
alternative facts or or disinformation
outside of politics and politics were so
familiar with it an ideal to deal with
everyday coronavirus is exposing that in
medicine and of course quack medicine
Sham medicine I think we may understand
that one but what are other sort of
centers of disinformation well I look at
it this way disinformation is created
for a purpose this information is not an
accident
so disinformation is created when
somebody has a financial interest or a
political interest or an ideological
interest in getting people to believe
something that isn't true
so when you say outside politics I don't
know if you're including Russia in that
because one thing that I found very
interesting for the last few days is if
you look at the Twitter handles that are
trending for the last several days new
Twitter handles in American politics
start to trend at around 3 o'clock in
the morning which is you know amazingly
well that's wake up time over in Moscow
so they're messing with their politics
they're messing with our Twitter handles
as we knew now examples out saying you
also mentioned science denial I mean if
you think about what are the fossil fuel
industries what a big tobacco you know
those sorts of people with financial
interests what do they have to gain by
creating disinformation I mean I'm sure
there are other examples that I could
give but you know you you think of if
you think of the political and
ideological examples you think of the
economic examples those are really the
big ones these days but I think that
anytime somebody is telling you
something that you kind of wonder does
that person have a stake in that being
true it should make you skeptical when
we are thinking now about what needs to
happen from here until whenever we start
to see a change in the in the trends
with what's going on with coronavirus it
seems to me that when for example Fox
and Friends says this is actually a
great time to fly the planes are empty
the airports are empty this is fantastic
there is actually a real human risk
particularly when Fox News's audience
skews disproportionately old to
perpetuating this stuff yeah what do we
do I mean what can we do it's that the
old folks aren't watching my show so I
have no access to them right so what how
do we manage this stuff it's it's
difficult I
I heard tell that last night Fox News
all of a sudden started to wake up a
little bit
yes tucker carlson and a few other
people started to say you know you
really have to get serious about this
and then trump started to take it more
seriously talked about not congregating
in groups of more than 10 you know etc
so you know and we've known for some
time that there's a little bit of a
feedback loop between Trump and and Fox
News I mean one thing that I've
advocated for a long time which is
particularly hard now that we're all in
lockdown I mean we're all sheltering in
place but the thing that I've advocated
is engagement people get information
from people that they trust and so maybe
they turn on the news and you know do
they trust what's coming from the news
or from political figures that they
trust maybe they do but they also trust
their friends and neighbors they also
trust their family and so I think it's
really important that we have those
conversations and there's a lot of
anecdotal information which shows that
that works in science miles say that's
how you get somebody to change their
mind about climate change that's how you
get somebody to change their mind about
anti VAX the trusting relationship is
the place to share that information so
you know we can't give up giving that
the truth out there is really important
is there any particular set of is there
a profile of the types of folks that are
more likely to open-mindedly reassess
their beliefs in the sense that you
might say well it's intuitive that older
folks are less likely to reassess their
beliefs because they've held their
beliefs for a longer period of time that
may be completely false right well are
there some of those characteristics that
let us build a profile of who is most
likely to be open to changing their mind
there's some empirical work right now
going on is and I'm a philosopher I'm
not a social scientist so I'm not sure
I'm the best messenger for this but
there is some empirical work going on
where they're trying to measure whether
or not belief and say conspiracy
theories correlates with liberal versus
conservative worldview and the trouble
with this kind of researching is I mean
you can always think of it
options you can always you know think of
examples where you know what about this
what about that in in my own research
you know in the work that I've done on
science and I'll or not post truth I
haven't really noticed that you know the
old versus young you know rich versus
poor I guess what I I guess I'm
accepting this as a as a fact we all
have cognitive bias the book by Daniel
Kahneman called Thinking Fast and Slow
shows the cognitive biases are built
into all of us and so I think it's
dangerous to just say you know well you
know everybody who believes in
conspiracy theories skews right or
everybody who believes in you know
denial coronavirus skews old or
something like that for one it may not
be true for another I think it overlooks
the reality which is that we all have to
be on our guard against these mind bugs
if you want to think of it that way this
ability to believe something because we
want to believe but that's really the
danger so you know I I can get something
of an answer to this to say look at the
literature you know on this because
there is even with people working with
fMRIs on this which is really
interesting work but I don't want people
just to dismiss this as somebody else's
problem because post truth is
everybody's problem
well medical stuff and in particular
anti-vaccine terrestris party lines so
when you look at anti-vaccine the right
who are anti vaccine government trying
to control them they're distrustful of
government people on the Left say it's
for-profit big pharma trying to you know
pump heavy metals into us or whatever
very different political views but they
end up in some kind of strange strange
bedfellows sort of situation you're
absolutely right and the other thing to
notice about anti facts is that they
tend to skew more educated as well and
which is a really interesting thing
because you know you think of somebody
going you know baby being skeptical
maybe they're scared and then they go to
the internet and they start to do their
research and they maybe they find out
liable information then they do more
research and you know we in the trade
you know going down the rabbit hole
right think of it that way but that's
the same way that flat earthers are
created right they get on YouTube they
start to look at the videos next thing
you know they they end up there so you
know it's it's really fascinating to me
that somebody can be very well educated
and still believe some of these things
and I think some of what it has to do in
the literature bears me out here is that
sometimes what happens is as somebody's
better educated they're more able to
defend and their views you know you talk
to some people who deny climate change
and you know they can be really up on
some of the laters literature what they
don't know how to do is to reason like a
scientist they don't know how to use
that evidence and that literature you
know to to make the important point not
to cherry-pick
not to expect you know zero uncertainty
before they have a belief that's the
problem that they're really missing is
not you know some particular data point
that they can use to shove down your
throat but how scientists reason about
data very very well said we've been
speaking with Lee MacIntyre research
fellow at the Center for philosophy and
history of science at Boston University
the book post truth is out and you can
check it out using the link in the
description to the YouTube video for
this discussion Lee always a pleasure
having you on oh thank you so much I
really enjoyed it the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
it's Donald Trump lying about having
been tested for coronavirus and testing
negative now I'm not suggesting from
didn't test negative although it
wouldn't surprise me that if from had
tested positive they simply wouldn't
tell us but the timing and especially
Donald Trump's very weird answer
yesterday when he was asked about what
it was like to be tested it all sounds
very strange and I don't know that
Donald Trump was actually tested so
let's go through it first starting with
the question yesterday during Trump's
coronavirus press conference Trump's
first answer about the timing and
results of his test you had your own a
virus test Friday night though the White
House doctor's office put out a
statement around midnight Friday saying
that no test was indicated so when
exactly was your test administered oh I
had my test I was late Friday night and
the reason I did it was because the I
had no symptoms whatsoever so the doctor
said you have no symptoms so we don't
see any reason but when I did the press
conference and fire everybody was going
crazy did you do the test did you do the
test so very late on Friday night I did
the test and he may have put out or the
doctor may have put out something at a I
don't know what time the letter went out
maybe it was put up by somebody else but
the results came back I believe the
following day and we tested negative
half of the White House doctor's office
wasn't indicated employment you hadn't
had one when in fact you had well I told
them that and I went totally by what
they said the doctors more than one they
said you don't have any of the symptoms
they checked what you're supposed to
check and that I didn't have symptoms
but I did it I did a test late on Friday
night and it came back probably 24 hours
later or something they sent it to the
labs came back so understand the
timeline that Trump is suggesting here
combined with what we know Friday at
3:30 Trump was asked during his press
conference about being tested and he
said I have no symptoms I don't need to
be tested but maybe someday I will be
Friday evening the White House said
Trump doesn't need to be tested but then
Trump now claims that late on Friday he
was tested for coronavirus if the White
House puts out a statement saying nobody
worried Trump doesn't even need
thing why would he have been tested
basically at the exact same time that
the White House was putting out that
statement and then Trump claims that
Saturday evening so fewer than 24 hours
from when he was supposedly tested he
got a negative test result for a corona
virus so the question is a good one if
at 3:00 p.m. you said no symptoms no
need for a test if at night a doctor
said no symptoms no need for a test
why were you immediately tested and then
there's also the question of tests are
taking longer than 20 hours or 18 hours
now of course maybe when it's the
president they fast track it we don't
know but they said that they are hopeful
someday we will get to 24 hour
turnaround on tests we're not there yet
at this point in time if the test was
done very late Friday as Trump says and
then early on Saturday evening the
results were already announced that is
way less than the 48 to 72 hour range
that is typically the one that's also
weird but then we get to the real
whopper and this is this is what Fermi
suggested this guy's not been tested
Trump was asked about the test and the
test requires a swab to be inserted
pretty deeply into the nose to get to
the throat it's not comfortable
most people gag tear up Koff etc which
is why the people doing the tests have
to be in full medical protective gear
and Trump responds in a way where it
doesn't seem like he knows how the test
is done and so he says something very
vague to avoid saying something that is
known to be untrue about the test itself
check it out and let me know what you
think now not something I want to do
every day I can tell you that it's a you
know it's a little bit of a it's a
little bit of good doctors in the White
House but it's a test it's a test it's a
medical test nothing Pleasant about it
it's a test it's a medical test and I
wouldn't you know recommend it's not
something I would want to do again does
this sound to anybody else like a
completely fabricated story that he made
up completely on the spot so let me know
what you think do you think Trump is
lying about having been tested at all do
you think Trump is lying about the
negative result if you said to me is the
lie about the result or is the lie
about being tested I think the lies
about being tested not not not about the
result although I do think they would
likely lie about the result as well let
me know what you think I don't know one
of the really sad and tragic things that
too often happens in bad situations is
that grifters come out of the woodwork
with new grifts that target exactly the
most vulnerable people at any particular
time in this case with the corona virus
some of the most vulnerable people are
older folks often who watch fox news
often who watch televangelist Christian
TV now I already told you last week how
this Christian lunatic Jim Baker was
told by the New York Attorney General
stopped promoting this bogus silver
solution cure for coronavirus it's not a
cure it can be harmful to people's
health drinking silver solution and
similar so-called colloidal silver can
make it so your body doesn't properly
absorb antibiotics and other other
medications they can start to turn your
skin sort of a bluish gray it's bad stop
saying it cures coronavirus I have
another one for you today and it just so
happens to be another Christian lunatic
this one's Kenneth Copeland healing
people of the virus through the TV
Kenneth Copeland if you're not familiar
with him is this 83 year old
televangelist worth are reported 760
million dollars thanks to a very
successful multi-decade grift that he's
been running and he has used his grift
to fund private jets to fund a very
lavish lifestyle and here he is visibly
sort of sweaty with some kind of I'm
sure special healing water on his hand
healing his viewers mostly old folks who
are at risk through the TV during a very
quote special report called standing
against coronavirus we need vaccines we
need antivirals we need actual medical
treatments standing against coronavirus
with prayer through the TV is not what
we need but that's what he's offering
put your hand on that television set yes
Jesus thank you Lord Jesus
he received your hailing yes now say it
I take it I have it I have it's mine
it's mine I thank you and praise you for
it
yes and I forgive if I have aught
against any and I praise you that I'm
well and whole I praise you that I'm
according to the Word of God I'm healed
yes and I consider not my own body yes I
consider not symptoms in my body I
consider not symptoms but only that
which God has promised only that what
the word has said by His stripes I was
healed and by His stripes I am healed
now I'm not the sick trying to get
healed on the heel and the devil's
trying to give me the flute three or
whatever else kind of thing he's trying
yeah heal and well yes in a sweet name
in Jesus people are more likely to die
if they believe that this works because
they are more at risk of dying if they
get coronavirus because these are older
audiences that watch this nonsense this
should be illegal but it's not
he makes gobs of money with this
nonsense and I hate to break it to you
but it's not just lunatic Christian
televangelists that are doing this Trump
has been doing it Rush Limbaugh has been
doing it Fox and Friends has been doing
it Trump tweeted the day before
yesterday a couple days ago in his
infinite
orange wisdom and leadership quote today
is a National Day of Prayer god bless
everyone what we need is a day of
testing not a day of prayer we need a
day of procuring ventilators not
blessings that we need people to stay
home not to go to churches and if we're
going
to pray for anything it should be for a
competent person to take over dealing
with this pandemic crisis and of course
remember once you bring God into it the
obvious question is all of this is just
up to God why didn't God stop
coronavirus why did God allow or create
coronavirus wouldn't it be simpler
easier better instead of creating or
allowing coronavirus and then waiting
for people to pray enough for God to
stop it why not just skip coronavirus
altogether oval bow David David God
works in mysterious ways maybe we
haven't been praying hard enough right
we're done folks as a society if this is
what we're counting on insert bogus
lunatic talking point here this stuff is
truly vile it should be illegal we have
a voicemail number that number is two
one nine two david p a couple of
voicemails today going to try to insert
a little bit of levity and some less
serious topics at a time that is that is
a challenging one for all of us let's
take a listen to the first voicemail
today hi david pakman this is Aaron I
was just kind of curious why I only hear
men calling in as you can hear in the
background only a man but anyway it
would be interesting to see what women
have to say right as well anyway I love
your show and I love the success you're
having so have a good day yeah and this
is actually less about our show we are
the ad agency our ad sales program has
expanded into an ad agency and we
actually represent a lot of online talk
shows for ad sales and all of our
demographics for political online shows
skew mail this is not something unique
to the David Pakman show in fact we have
more of a female audience than many
other shows that are in our cohort that
are similar shows to ours and it's
something about the format even shows
that have a bigger female presence
hosting
often have a smaller female audience
than our show then we work with other
other types of shows that have a much
more balanced a audience gender wise as
far as that goes so that isn't that is
an interesting thing all right one other
voicemail that's this kind of a funny
funny allusion to Susan Collins the
perennial e disappointed Republican
senator hey David a spawn stay I'm good
point in the show today I haven't
listened to it or anything I just know
it's gonna be disappointing right all
right thanks all right well listen I I
apologize that I am letting people down
in all seriousness it has been I don't
know if heartwarming is the right term
it feels sort of apocryphal to call it
that cliche in a sense but I have been
so thrilled to see that in what are very
difficult times for a lot of people for
large portions of the country that are
actually doing what we need to do to try
to deal with coronavirus that so many
people have been getting in touch and
saying what you're providing is a really
valuable service thanks for staying on
top of the virus thanks for staying on
top of politics while all of this is
going on thanks for rearranging
production in a way to allow all of this
to continue the live streams we streamed
yesterday's trump coronavirus of press
conference across YouTube twitch and
Facebook we had about 16,000 live
viewers which for us that's a great live
stream for us so there's clearly a
desire to have information we're doing
everything we can to provide it to
people and we're going to continue and
it continues tonight I hope you'll join
me at 8:00 p.m. Eastern for the a
primary results live stream on the bonus
show today we are going to dig in more
not to the US stock market collapse but
the world stock market collapse Europe
Asia and and others and I have a few
personal stories to tell you about it
also it's not just toilet paper that
people are hoarding people are starting
to buy guns and ammo over concerns
around martial law may be being declared
leading to people having to fend for
themselves in a way that might require
guns now the funny thing about it or
ironic
often when martial law is declared guns
are sometimes seized so we'll talk about
that and then lastly Mitt Romney has a
coronavirus plan that sounds a lot like
Andrew Yang's thousand bucks a month
universal basic income plan so we will
talk about all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show grab a membership
at join pakman.com or make a patreon
pledge at patreon.com slash david pakman
show to get instant access I will speak
to you then
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]